depuis le 11 novembre 2022 toutes les
volailles ont été mises à l'abri pour
éviter la propagation de la grippe
aviaire une situation difficile pour les
producteurs de bio et de plein air qui
doivent également faire face à
l'explosion de leur coût de production
que ce soit au niveau de l'énergie ou de
l'alimentation on en parle plus
précisément avec notre invité du jour
Céline Brouard bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes éleveuse de poules pondeuses
en bio alors aujourd'hui vous demandez
une revalorisation du prix d'achat de
vos oeufs pour couvrir vos coûts de
production
expliquez-nous quelle est la situation
et bien la situation est très compliquée
en élevage bio en fait depuis
2022 nous avons un cahier des charges
qui s'est renforcé et dans le même temps
on a une très forte augmentation du coût
de l'aliment de l'énergie pour
travailler dans nos élevages et la main
d'oeuvre également énormément augmenté
le coût de toutes les matières avec
lesquelles on travaille tout ce qui est
produit de soins pour nos animaux donc
on a un prix qui aujourd'hui nous est
payé en tant qu'elveur sur une base de
18 centimes l’œuf ce qui ne permet pas
de couvrir toutes les charges que nous
avons puisque nous avons une
augmentation des charges de l'ordre de
30 à 40% combien il vous faudrait
combien il faudrait vous acheter l’œuf
pour que vous vous en sortir j'allais
dire alors aujourd'hui en fait ce qu'on
aimerait c'est que l'oeuf arrive à
approximativement 20 centimes de sorte
de pouvoir nous rémunérer parce
qu'aujourd'hui en fait on ne peut plus
rémunérer tel qui tel qu'il en est alors
on nous dites notre offre il nous coûte
18 il nous est acheté 18 centimes
d'euros c'est ça voilà aujourd'hui dans
la grande distribution on trouve à
combien alors la moyenne des prix sur un
relevé que j'ai fait hier on est à peu
près à 52 centimes sur un œuf bio ça
peut aller même jusqu'à 68 centimes j'ai
vu des endroits où il était vendu 68
centimes donc c'est vrai que quand nous
on est payé 18 centimes et qu'on le
trouve que le consommateur le trouve en
magasin à 60 et bien là on se demande ou
passe l'argent
sachant que on sait aussi que le travail
du centre de conditionnement se situe à
peu près à aux alentours de 4 centimes
pour sortir un œuf donc c'est vrai que
notre colère elle est là on aimerait la
grande taille les grands des moyennes
distribution qui sont une marge énorme
sur le prix de vos oeufs
c'est la grande distribution qui doit
rogner sur ses marges de sorte de
pouvoir nous en restituer une partie
parce que on est on est vraiment
complètement bloqué est-ce qu'il y a une
baisse du ralentissement des achats de
en bio ce qu'on dit que les
consommateurs comme ils ont quand même
le portefeuille n'est pas extensible non
plus ben rogne sur la qualité de ce
qu'ils achètent alors c'est vrai qu'en
début de journée un consommateur qui va
faire ses courses va plutôt s'orienter
ses achats vers un neuf de code 3 ou de
code 2 et sur la fin de journée étant
donné qu'il y a beaucoup moins d'œufs
dans les rayons il va se retrancher sur
un œuf de plein air ou en bio et dans ce
cas il est obligé forcément de l'acheter
plus cher on parle désormais de
déconversion c'est un nouveau mot que
j'ai découvert c'est à dire quitté le
circuit bio pour retourner vers le
conventionnel est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ce
serait une porte de sortie pour vous
alors pour moi c'est vraiment enfin la
dernière des sorties que je prendrai
parce que je suis éleveur bio depuis 17
ans et je suis convaincue par l'élevage
bio maintenant je sais qu'il y a des
collègues qui sont en déconversion pour
pouvoir répondre à une demande en plein
air mais c'est vrai que c'est un choix
de produire un œuf quand il n'est pas
produit en bio ah oui ça coûte un peu
moins cher après c'est vrai que le
cahier des charges n'est pas du tout le
même c'est vraiment la grosse différence
avec ce cahier des charges qui a été a
été vraiment accentuée de manière
importante l'année dernière bon écoutez
merci Céline boire j'espère que les
consommateurs auront entendu votre appel
merci à vous